castle point and rochford health and
well-being strategy reset
asian whale workshop from the 9th of
september 2020
facilitated by nancy smith who is the
commissioning manager for dementia and
older people's mental health southend
castle point and rockford aging well
what do we know older people are more
likely to live with multiple and complex
long-term conditions
or with frailty or dementia the older
you are
the more activity you need the more
long-term conditions you have
the more activity you need
aging well considerations for today
frailty including falls and fractures
and long-term conditions dementia
older people's mental health and excess
winter deaths
questions to consider as you look at the
data one
what does the data tell us two what are
the key themes identified
three what additional issues or effects
has covered 19
had on aging well and how might that
differ from what we see here
life expectancy versus healthy life
expectancy
according to government data life
expectancy at birth
is 80 years for males and 83 years for
females in castle point
in rochford life expectancy at birth is
81.4 years
for males and 84.4 years for females
however health inequalities mean that
some people will spend more years of
their lives in poor health than
others the difference in life expectancy
between the most and least the private
areas of castle point
is five years for males and 4.8 years
for females
whereas in rockford the difference in
life expectancy is higher for females at
4.1 years
and 3.3 years for males between the most
and least deprived areas
this data was obtained from phe
fingertips
falls and hip fractures the 2019 jsna
profiles state that castle point and
rockford
had the second and third highest rates
of emergency hospital admissions due to
falls
in people over 65 across the essex
district
castle point had 2362.11
per 100 000 population and rochford had
eight point 2258.5 one per hundred
thousand population
the highest was basildon with two
thousand six hundred
and seventy seven point one zero the
lowest was harlow
with 1742.48
both are higher than the rate across
essex which was 2059.46
and england which was 2170.43
basel and castle point and rochford were
the only districts in essex with a
higher rate than england
the age standardized rate of emergency
hospital admissions due to hit fractures
among over 65
was lower than the rate across essex as
a whole which was 611.9
however both castle point and rockford
had rates that were higher
than england which was 577.76
with 588.79 and 607.61
this is the 2017-18 data from the
hospital episode statistics
the figures stated are age standardized
rates of emergency hospital admissions
due to falls and hip fractures values
given are per 100 000 population
physical activity in older adults 75
plus
the latest comparable data from sports
england's active
lives survey shows that 56.4 percent of
adults in castle point
and 49.5 in rochford are inactive
this means doing less than 30 minutes of
physical activity a day
we have been monitoring the impact of
kovid 19 on physical
cognitive and emotional well-being
across southeast essex
from the start of lockdown and have seen
considerable deterioration across older
people
we have also seen considerable
deterioration in residents of care homes
causing upset to visiting families
numbers of people referred for the full
prevention program in castle point and
rockford in the last year
are not available but the future is
hopeful
physical activity opportunities since
march at the start of lockdown many
organizations shifted their mode of
delivery to online
offering a range of virtual activity
sessions active essex launched a youtube
channel called keep ethics active
with a weekly timetable of activities
for people of all ages
sport for confidence occupational
therapists and sport coaches delivered
sessions on zoom to offer specialist
support at home
some group face-to-face sessions have
since resumed where possible
such as the action for family carers
feeling good caring well
well-being walks for carers dementia
figures
compared to pre-covered figures recorded
in february the latest figures from july
show that the number of people recorded
with dementia
in castle point and rockford has
decreased from 1836
to 1780. meanwhile the estimated number
of people with dementia has increased
from 2800 2828 to 2849
the number of people being supported has
also increased from 972 to 1266.
the percentage recorded in february was
64.9 percent
and in july was 62.5 both of which are
below the nhs england target
of 66.7 percent for southend a total of
1764 people were recorded in july
and 238 estimated
compared to 1909 recorded
and 2405 estimated to have dementia in
february
across the whole of the mid and south
essex area the percentage recorded has
dropped from 65.8 percent in february
to 61.8 percent in july
this is the same as a national picture
with 63.2 percent of over 65s fought to
have dementia in july
compared to 67.6 in february
nancy smith commented on this saying we
have put a lot of effort into continue
to diagnose
people remotely in ways that are safe
and acceptable to people
but completely different to what they
are used to
projections according to the projecting
older people's population information
the number of people in castle point and
rockford with dementia age 65 and over
is projected to increase by 46 by the
year 2035.
although a number of people under 65 of
dementia is projected to stay the same
at around 50 people in castle point and
rockford
combined how much can we rely on these
figures
it's probably somewhat debatable it also
doesn't take into account people with
mild cognitive
impairment who might be on the register
as well
louisa morris commented on this data
saying we need to be mindful of
statistics as they are going to be a lot
bigger than those shown here
spencer dinesh commented on the dementia
data saying
when talking about dementia we only talk
about the over 65s but it is important
to support all ages
older people's mental health 20 of those
living in a community and 40
of those living in a care home have
depression numbers using
improved access to psychology therapies
is 138 since april
with the biggest increase in july and
august some of the particular problems
for older people experiencing depression
are as follows
physical symptoms and depression some
physical illnesses can give you symptoms
that are similar to those in depression
for example loss of appetite or poor
sleep can be caused by thyroid problems
heart disease or arthritis long-term
illness
if you become depressed you may start to
get more upset by your health
even though it hasn't really changed for
the worse treating the depression
can't take away any physical health
problems but it can make them much
more bearable confusion and memory
problems
depression worry and anxiety can affect
your memory
and make you feel confused you may worry
that you are
suffering from dementia when it is
actually just depression
a new sense of loneliness living alone
does not automatically make you
depressed
but feeling more lonely for no obvious
reason may be a sign of depression
depression in older people can be caused
by physical health problems and
long-term conditions
low mood and memory problems feeling
less interested in everyday activities
declining social invitations and
bereavement for carers
isolation and loneliness exacerbates the
feelings of depression and anxiety
excess winter deaths excess winter
deaths are defined as the excess winter
deaths measured as the ratio of extra
deaths from all causes
that occur in the winter months compared
with expected number of deaths
based on the average of the number of
non-winter deaths
expressed as a percentage government
data from 2017 to 18
shows that excess winter deaths are
higher in castle point at 43
and ruptured at 45.3 than the england
and east of england values
the excess winter deaths index for
people aged 85 plus
is higher in ruptured at 76 compared to
43.4 in castle point
both areas are higher than the england
and east of england values
according to the office of national
statistics colder than average
temperatures for the winter months of
2017 to 2018
may partially explain the increase in
winter deaths however previous years
demonstrate a weak relationship between
temperature and
excess winter deaths increased excess
winter deaths are not always coupled
with unusually cold winters and
conversely winters
with decreased excess winter deaths are
not always coupled with
milder winter temperatures indicating
factors other than temperature
such as influenza are also relevant in
explaining trends
in excess winter mortality
winter worries the following are worries
that have come to our attention when
thinking about the effect of winter
flu season longer darker evenings
cognitive decline falls emotional
decline
isolation loneliness depression
anxiety second wave of covid
lockdown and associated problems lack or
loss of community services and
opportunities
mental health and family and friends
other factors to consider are
wider determinants of health deprivation
housing conditions
fuel poverty barriers that may present
challenges but also opportunities
and direct and indirect effects of
covid19
questions and considerations what does
the data tell us
what are the key themes identified what
additional issues or effects has covered
19 had on aging well
and how might that differ from what we
see here
how can we improve access to services
for older people
sue mari commented on that saying kovid
has changed what people thought was
going to be their lives
she also commented in this discussion
saying we have seen a huge reduction in
the number of people coming to us for
debt advice
nancy smith suggested that we need to
acknowledge the number of older people
with debt problems
while louise and moss believes we need
to personalize things even more
it's not as simple as asking for one
thing
next steps what other data do we need to
have to inform and provide more insight
who else needs to be involved we will be
meeting as a subgroup before the
december board meeting to continue
discussion
and develop the narrative around this
priority and start thinking about some
actions
how are we tackling the problems and
what other actions would help us to
address them
in terms of early intervention and
prevention
counselor julie gooding commented that
the hub has proven that we can all work
together
sue murray added that partnership work
has become essential
and suggested we need to give a holistic
approach